well I guess it matters in electoral
terms because a big row between the
sitting prime minister and his
predecessor open Warfare on the record
Warfare between those two
um isn't good for the Tories electorally
you know the old cliche of divided
parties don't win elections well it's
true
um I I think it's interesting watching
Rishi sunak's response more than Boris
Johnson's I think Boris Johnson's sort
of bombastic words about talking rubbish
in the last half an hour to be expected
what is unusual is Rishi sunak In that
clip you saw from that speech this
morning has clearly decided that he
doesn't want to just try and dampen all
of this down and hope it will Peter out
he actually wants to hit back and try
and put some distance between him and
Boris Johnson and try to return to one
of the sort of founding messages that um
he put out there when he went into
number 10 which was that he wants to
restore sort of discipline and process
and stability to government and I think
think the calculation behind the scenes
is probably that the damage that could
be done by inflaming the situation is
not as big as the damage that could be
done if Rishi sunak doesn't show a bit
of strength towards Boris Johnson now
and try and put a bit of clear blue
water between him
um and his and his predecessor in terms
of like who comes out on the upside of
this well I think it's interesting to to
see that since Richardson made those
remarks this morning and since Grant
chaps a senior minister in Michigan's
government came out and made some pretty
Punchy remarks about the world moving on
from Boris Johnson yesterday we haven't
seen any more resignations we haven't
seen any more Boris Johnson allies up in
arms and in fact talking to one Boris
Johnson supporter and friend of the
former prime minister sir Jake Berry
this morning he actually sounded pretty
mild-mannered on it all and pretty
supportive of the sitting prime minister
have a listen
I saw the prime minister's comments
earlier today I mean you know I think I
think the point is that I have no idea
about private conversations that took
place between the Prime Minister and
Rishi sunaka and you know I'm sure that
both of them are absolutely Beyond
reproach in this regard and um you know
if people are to draw more than sort of
he said she said conclusion from it then
I guess we're gonna have to find out
more I look forward to seeing it would
you like to see him back in the comments
um he's a great embarrass Johnson he's a
fantastic conservative a brilliant
parliamentarian and appeals to the Great
British public in a way that I've never
really seen any other politician do more
than Richardson
I think there is just something special
about him he's an extraordinary
character
I guess over and above the sort of
politics in all of this there are two
key points of process as well one is on
the Lord's appointment
um commission and the process by which
people are put into the House of Lords
to oversee the passage of legislation
and laws through Parliament
um now the the row between Boris Johnson
and Richie sunacrests on whether Boris
Johnson allies who were sitting MPS were
able to essentially accept their
peerages but not take it up until after
the next general
um election number 10 essentially a
saying that the commission that vets
nominations said on a pointer principle
know that wasn't possible Boris Johnson
is now saying that he believes it was
possible they just would have needed to
re-vet them at a later stage I think
more broadly does this sort of sap
increasingly sap people's confidence in
the whole process by which people are
put into the House of Lords and are made
legislators the second Point here is
about the Privileges committee and the
report there as well they have met
earlier today to find finalize their
inquiry we're expecting that report in
the coming days as well I think if that
is massively critical of Boris Johnson
if there is stuff in there that is new
about potential breaches of lockdown and
what he did and didn't tell the commons
um at the time I think that could do it
for Boris Johnson frankly and that could
be why the risk of that could be why now
Rishi sunak and number 10 are deciding
it's time to try and put distance
between the current Administration and
Boris Johnson and essentially as Grant
chap said yesterday move on from the
period of Boris Johnson